thank you mike and um thanks to everyone
for
still being here on friday at least all
of you who are here so
so um i'm going to talk about symmetric
product codes
um i guess i should note in the in the
based on that not not really because of
the theme of the workshop but just by
chance
um this actually does make sense from
practice to theory
because really the motivation to look at
these codes came from the fact that
people are using things in practice that
really
really
worked quite well and then we decided to
start playing with them we realized that
there's some interesting things about
these
as well so the beginning is going to be
i think straightforward for many people
but at least we'll get our notation
straight and talk about
what we're doing so we're going to
assume that we have a linear nkd code
this of course means block length n
dimension k minimum distance d over some
finite field f we have a generator
matrix
and a parity check matrix of the correct
dimensions
so the way i'm defining a product code
is i'm just finding an encoder where i
take some
information matrix which is k by k of my
field
and i'm going to do the standard
encoding which is ug which would encode
all of the rows and then when i hit it
with g transpose on the other side i
encode all the columns
so this is going to be the set of
matrices where every row and column of
the matrix
is a code word of this code c
it is well known this is an n squared k
squared d squared code it's nice
fits the the description product code
quite well
what we want to think about is what
happens when we look at uh first
symmetric sub codes
so what do i mean i'm saying so my code
words here are these matrices
so i'm going to call them x so they're n
by n matrices
and i'm going to ask for the matrix to
be symmetric so that its transpose is
equal to itself
um okay
and so so let u be the symmetric sub
code
and in this case what we can see is that
if we're in characteristic not equal to
2
actually this constraint is doesn't
matter if you're going to do the proof
more in a
longer way but it's easy to see that if
you can take one half times x transpose
plus x you will always get a symmetric
matrix and it turns out your code is
given by this take all your code words
take the average of the coder and its
transpose and you'll get this
now this matrix is going to still be n
by n but since it's symmetric we might
want to puncture the repeated symbols
so we're going to do is puncture the
lower triangle and now if you count
the number of entries in the upper
triangle including the diagonal of a
matrix
you find there are n plus 1 times n on 2
and so we have an n plus one times an on
two
if you do another calculation you find
that whenever you encoded a symmetric
information block
you got a symmetric code word you can
find the dimension that is k
plus one times k on two and if you then
look at your minimum distance code word
and see how it projects down into this
puncturing operation
you'll find that it's the minimum
distance code words which are well known
here
become d plus 1 times dn2
all right so in some sense what we've
done is we've gotten a code of roughly
half the length half the dimension and
half the minimum distance
whether this is good or not it's not
clear let's look at this in pictures
so we have our product code rows in
every row and column is a coder to this
matrix and now what i'm going to do is
the symmetric subcode i'm just saying
i'm going to just reverse these indices
so i put the same block
lower part and then i puncture it
all right so what are the benefits for
moderate k
n so the length and dimension is reduced
by about a factor of two
this can actually just by itself be
beneficial in practice so it's a code of
very similar properties but half the
length and half the dimension so roughly
the same rate
and maybe this reduces your delay by two
of course there's probably some penalty
but
the first order there's not much penalty
all right
also if you wanted to use the same
component code
the problem is the minimum distance also
drops by two
and so this is of course undesirable now
let's think about what we might do
to fix this let's instead take the
anti-symmetric sub code of p
so i'm going to ask that when i
transpose my matrix i get minus
x if my field has characteristic not 2
that's sufficient to describe it and
characteristics two which is where we
usually work of course
minus x is equal to x so this is a
becomes a trivial statement so all we
want to do then is zero out the diagonal
so the key the key element of this
description
is that it zeroes out the diagonal and
so
now we can think of this and fortunately
this description
without the the two there still works if
you take any code or in the difference
with its transpose that's going to have
a zero diagonal even in characteristic
two so you can basically think of
encoding
any two code words and taking their
difference
or taking any code when it's transposed
and taking their difference
so this construction which um is called
a half product code
was uh suggested by zeusten and he
suggested puncturing the lower triangle
this time including the zeros and the
diagonal and you're going to get an in
to choose two k choose two because now
we're not taking the diagonal
in our code and either the information
bits or the um
code bits and it's going to have some
distance so when he suggested it he
he he stated that the distance is the
same as before d plus one
or in this case d choose two but that's
not
exactly right all right so in this case
again i have our product code
now i'm putting the whole thing in red
to represent this is now the negative
of this upper triangle um and then we're
gonna
drop it put zeros here
all right so that this is the the main
example
at the end we're going to see that this
the idea behind this maybe
occurs more generally but we'll focus on
this example
now to see why how we came to think
about these codes
uh let's start with a little background
so product codes were just introduced a
long time ago
um even the iterative decoding was
introduced a long time ago
even the density evolution analysis of
their decoding
was introduced a long time ago although
uh it's actually hard to find it's
the proof of a lima which is in the
appendix of tanner's paper
you realize he's the first person to do
dense evolution for these codes you know
in 81 well just when they're hamming
component codes
all right so what happens in the
iterative decoder we're going to show an
example where we have two error
correcting codes with bounded distance
to coding
so we're showing a binary array the red
marks indicate errors
and so we say what happens when we
decode
the rows well every row that has one or
two errors can be corrected
now we're going to make the assumption
that we don't miscorrect at least in
this example
and so they'll be corrected now when we
do column decoding
every column which just has one or two
errors can be corrected
and now we're turning to row decoding we
get everything
this is the dakota that's used in
practice you can define a little more
complicated decoder which
is easier to analyze and kind of
provably works better
but nobody uses it what happens to this
decoder is it can get stuck in what's
called a stopping set
these are the natural generalization of
stopping sets in ldpc codes to this
problem
they're well known they can also relate
it to cores and random graphs
so in this case because i can only
correct two errors if i have any
square sub sub matrix which has a three
by three set of errors i'm going to be
stuck
all right so the application that i
think brought these to the interest of
people working the theory of coding
has been high-speed optical
communication so around 2010
giusen wrote a paper where he basically
listed all
variants of product codes that might be
useful for this application
it's a nice paper in terms that it
really but it doesn't say much about
each one but it says you can do this
this this this
they should all work well he's right of
course
some of them work slightly better than
others turns out in optical they started
with
a 239 255 reed solomon code so they like
to match that redundancy in general
they always talk about changing it but
you know they don't really want to
and so the high rate generalized product
codes with bch component codes appear as
a very good solution in this case
in particular there's this itu document
975.1
which also suggests 10 different
constructions
of these types of codes various
generalized product codes all of them
work pretty well
some of them work better than others and
so the decoding complexity though this
is an important note
is much lower than comparable ldpc codes
i'm going to talk about why in the next
slide
and for hard decision channels at high
rates
the ber performance is comparable so you
can't even really beat them by much
with ldbc codes in that regime
and so the key thing that i think makes
these interesting in practice is the
following
there's a very efficient decoder and the
decoder is based on syndrome
based iterative algebraic decoding so we
do is we receive our product
code word we calculate the syndromes of
all the rows and columns
and we store those and then we put the
bits away
so for example if i'm going to use a 10
23 993 bch code
instead of storing a length 10 23 vector
of
bits i'm going to store the 30 syndrome
bits for my iterative decoder
so that's a factor of 30 gain at that
point
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
run algebraic decoding on each of the
syndromes
and i'm going to keep track of where the
errors were there can't be too many
because i can only correct three errors
and i'm going to update the column
syndromes and likewise i'm going to run
algebraic decoding on the columns using
syndromes and update the rose syndromes
so i'm not going to even i'm going to
put this other data aside and not even
use it my iterative decoder can use a
much smaller memory that only stores the
syndromes
and where the locations of the errors
are in particular the memory to store
the syndromes is basically 2n
n minus k so i'm assuming binary here so
it's 2n squared 1 minus r
whereas if i had to store a log
likelihood ratio for each bit
in there it would be order n squared
this calculation assumes that i'm going
to
store three bits for each lor which is
i think a reasonable guess for for ldpc
and in that case my decoder
this not really my decoder the decoder
people have been using in industry for a
very long time
has a factor of 50 less memory than a
comparable
ldpc decoder so this is
you know in terms of power or running at
high rates this is an enormous
difference
so like i said it's well known in
industry for many years
but and then a few years back we had a
paper where we used spatial coupling to
prove these kinds of codes with
iterative hard decision to coding
can even achieve capacity as the rate
goes to one
now of course when the rates go into one
anything it's used capacity in some
sense
that what we mean by that is i mean
they're matching the redundancy the the
first non-trivial term
so if you expand capacity about rate one
this is a quick question for the lwc are
you assuming like edge storage
like one one no no i'm assuming one
i'm assuming non-edge storage so i can
one per variable
so i can i can put another factor of
three in there i suppose
if you can do that all right so
literally i don't think there's any i
could we no i don't know of any trick
for ldbc
that that reduces the memory to be
comparable
so if there is one i'd love to hear
about it but in the bch
you're scoring this one bit curve
well i'm just doing one bit for every
syndrome so i'm storing the syndrome
i'm not storing the information but it's
not received values right you have to
state but you're destroying them as hard
decisions or
uh yeah so they so you get a factor of
three right there i guess but
yeah yeah so maybe it's maybe it's not
fair
um so there's something hidden here so
let's think of it as memory accesses
for the ldbc decoder i have to multiply
this by the number of iterations
here i have to multiply this by the
number of iterations of course
everybody has to store the received
symbols so we both
pay a storage in squared but
i can put those in slow memory i can
keep them off chip or something like
this
so yeah are you restricted to use this
independent row and column decoding you
cannot
make those decoding top twitter like gmd
um so i'm restricted to use syndromes
so gmd uses more than syndromes right it
orders reliabilities
so if this is like the loss you get if
you're going to compress
everything down to a syndrome you kind
of lose the soft information so
i'm not you could certainly do that for
the decoder i don't see how to use gmd
with this single complexity decoder
right so what i mean
yeah we'll talk about it some other time
what can i do more than this i'm not
exactly sure
all right so what are we calling
symmetric product codes
so we're saying we're taking the
subclass of generalized product codes
where we're going to use symmetry to
reduce the block length and dimension
while keeping the same component code so
that's the general concept
and so this example that i'm focusing on
which is the nicest example for say
is what's called half product codes by
zeus and when he introduced them he
actually credited them
to uh tanner turns out tanner has a very
similar construction which we saw in
mary's talk she had a nice picture of it
and but the um it's not actually a
product code
in the sense that we want it's just a
gra it's a nice graphical
code what's your motivation for reducing
the block length
so uh so let's see what do i get in
terms of
of this i can have a 10 23 this is going
to be a block length a million code
so in optical right now if i give them a
block with a million code which performs
the same as a block like 500 000 code
they take the 500 000 every time
now when i go from 10 000 to five
thousand maybe people aren't quite as
interested
so this is a obviously they are still
interested in flash for example
but certainly saving five hundred
thousand of something seems more
impressive than saving a few thousand
we'll see
now so the thing uh i would say that
motivated us to write this
work up we've been doing some of this
krishna and i have been doing some of
this work
for a while and we had a student who we
said you know give us a fair comparison
kept pounding this guy to give us a fair
comparison and so he went away and like
we
we essentially had not been doing fair
comparisons but we didn't realize it
and he said well i need to match between
the product code
the block length and the dimension that
seems like a fair comparison
so he comes out and he says all right
well we knew the block length would
change by square two and we kind of knew
the dimension squared
too but we never put these two together
to say that means that the difference
also changes by square root two
and so that the half product code to be
fair actually
can correct square two more errors so if
you build a
uh if you have a product code with three
error correcting codes
you get a half product code and a fair
comparison corrects you know
four or more errors and so this actually
changes a lot of the properties in fact
it tells you that maybe the minimum
distance isn't because you're getting a
better code
the minimum distances might even be in
your favor as well
all right so now i'm going to attempt
one proof apologies in advance
i'm going to prove to you that the
minimum distance of these codes jumps up
by taking this symmetric or
anti-symmetric sub code
and so to do that we're going to have to
do something that i'm sure many
people know better than i which is the
idea of generalized hamming weights
and so they have to do with the weights
of sub codes of certain dimensions
we only need the very first one so it's
not too bad
what we need is the minimum over all
pairs of code words that are not zero
and not equal to each other
of the size of the union of their
support
and so that means if you try to take two
code words
and have them here and you and look at
the linear combinations is how how much
room is that going to take
we're going to see that's important so
it measures the minimum total support
of two code words now there's a very
simple bound on this
so you can say that has to be greater
than three times the minimum distance on
two
and otherwise you get a contradiction
because if you have two code words whose
whose total support is too small you can
add them together
and get below minimum distance so the
only thing you're seeing here is saying
that
they're smaller than that when you add
them together you get less than minimum
distance so
it's a very simple idea and so we have
this this is a i think this is a
well-known bound i think it also appears
in here
there's many more bounds that appear in
here ah i should tell you who that is
hello seth clove and yuchis that was
actually in way's original paper
way 91 had all those balance burdens
okay and even before that in a paper
that i
didn't find but i mean right before that
right
yesterday mentioned the generalized
timing weights in his talk
and it was way 91. all right
so um so we're going to look at the
anti-symmetric sub code
and we want to say this for any two code
words we're interested in code words of
the shape and these are kind of like the
canonical constructions of
low weight code words for product codes
you're going to take the outer product
of two code words
because you know essentially if you take
a code word on one side and a code on
the other and you take this outer
product
that's going to be a code word in your
product code
because when you hit it with on your
when you hit it with h on one side
you get zero and it doesn't matter what
that is
and so but we want to show that it's not
in the anti-symmetric sub code
so that means your minimum distance
patterns with these blocks of ones
associated with
minimum weight code words are not in
your antimatter
sub code and the reason is the diagonal
is zero so we're going to say because
the diagonal
we're forcing the diagonal of our code
words to be zero
we know that when we look at the ith
entry encodered1 and we multiply it by
the ith entry and code word
uh two it has to be zero
under this construction for oi and then
it tells me that these two
coders are start with have to have
disjoint support because if anywhere the
support overlaps they have a one in the
same position then i'll get a one on my
diagonal
okay and now what i say is if i
look at x i j so the i j entry in my
matrix
i'm going to say that x 1 i times x j is
not equal to 0
for some point assume that is true but
now when i when i transpose it
it becomes x 1 j x 2 i i know that
so basically when i switch this one from
i to j
these both have to be non-zero for this
to be non-zero
when i switch this one from i to j and
this one from j to i because the
supports are disjoint they both become
zero
so it says that if you choose the code
word this way it cannot be
anti-symmetric or symmetric so
we'll leave with that so thus any code
of this form
it's like this so why does that matter
well let's think about code words of
this form as essentially when you take
one code word say for your rows and this
x1 defines
scalar multiples of it so you're going
to take one code word and just put
scalar multiples in each row
and so it says there's no x and v where
non-zero rows are
scalar multiples of a single code word
so if they're not all scalar multiples
of a single code word there must be
two codewords two different code words
in this rows
and so now we say because there's no
scalar multiples
it must have at least two distinct
non-zero codes the minimum number of
columns
is therefore bounded by this second
generalized hamming weight so it's going
to be a little wider
and so likewise just by trivial bounds
each column has to have d non-zero
entries
so i get a bound instead of d squared i
get d times d2
right so minimum distance of my
anti-symmetric sub code is d2 times d
which i have this lower bound all right
when i puncture
it's symmetric and i've dropped out the
zero so i'm going to get half as many
ones
and so now i can i can divide again by
two so puncturing to get my half
product code which i'm calling this
script h and if d
is even this comes to a simple form of
3d squared on 4.
so basically i'm getting a factor of 3
half gain over minimum distance
so it's not an amazing factor but it's
enough
to make this code basically as good as
the full code
and so now i've got a code that's half
as long that's basically as good as the
original code
so that's the kind of practical
motivation of this
now if you work this out in more
generality you get
some you know things like this there's a
matching upper bound in some cases so
you know it's tight
we could probably make it match in all
cases with just a little more pain
so like i'll repeat the basic idea so
zeros on the diagonal present the
standard
square product square pattern code words
you get
in product codes once those go away you
kind of have to look at the next weight
and and that involves the second
generalized hemming weight so you get
this bound
so let's do an example so we say now if
we have an 844 extended hamming code
it turns out in this case my minimum
distance is even and my bound is tight
and so what i see is that i get a half
product code
which is a 28 6 12 binary linear code
because i'm going to have 3 times 4
squared on 4
which is 12. and if you look in the
table um
that's now compiled by marcus grassel
i'm not i can't remember who maybe it's
originally brower's code table
no binary linear code exists with larger
minimum distance and these parameters
it's a fairly weak statement when you
look at these tables but it's a true
statement
and one of the the upper bound does
require essentially when you find the
minimum for the
the generalized hemi weight you have to
have points that achieve it you have to
find the code words and achieve it and
calculate something
so to make it a tight bound all right so
now we have some we have some ideas so
this this in particular
i don't think this holds for any product
code there's no product code when you
take the product code
it actually has the best minimum
distance for those parameters maybe
it might be true for like a single
parity check or something but even then
i don't think all right so
now we want to use iterative decoding as
we talked about there are some analysis
techniques
so basically we're going to assume um
because it makes our life easier
that the receive symbols can be
corrected sequentially without mistakes
this always works on the bec on the bsc
we have to assume there's a genie that
keeps us from doing miss correction
the way it works is it's based on an
error graph so
what you do is you're going to take
every code constraint and call that a
vertex this is actually tanner's
representation
of these kinds of codes and every edge
is really a variable node and it and
it's and it
connects the two code constraints which
it's in
and when you have the initial
observations through your either erasure
channel or air channel
everywhere you get it right or you
observe it you can remove that edge
there's no problem and so now you have
this thing so what you have here is you
started with essentially a complete
graph
or maybe a complete bipartisan graph so
in the product code case it's a complete
bipartite
bipartite graph and the half product
code it's a complete graph
and you've you've removed all edges
independently with probability one minus
p
so you have an error sharing a random
graph and so it turns out when
you think of your decoder that peels any
code constraint which has two or fewer
edges this will always reach some
stopping stat
you're peeling your graph down after a
finite number of iterations
and some nice things happen in
particular
you can have asymptotic results that are
in this regime
where the lengths of the codes are
growing without bound but they're
correcting a fixed
number of errors say three error
correcting codes so of course the rate's
going to one it's a little bit of a
strange regime but
this is where you can actually prove
something and so we say is
n is going to infinity with fixed error
correction t
and i'm assuming that my error rate
scales like lambda on it
and this is actually the same as the
aerodynamic sparse
regime so that's nice the decoding
threshold can be seen as
comes from graph theory in solving the
k-core problem this was observed in 2007
and if you look at the thresholds you
get so if you assume you have two error
correcting product codes
and actually you should note this the
the problem is the same for the
product and half product so essentially
they have the same threshold so if you
take the same component code
half product and product have the same
threshold now first that sounds like
i've done something wow i have half a
long code
but since n is going to infinity that's
kind of a vacuous statement right i have
code that's half as long within going to
infinity they're both going to infinity
but for t equal to 2 3 and 4 i can find
these thresholds it says
if you have two are correcting codes you
can basically handle an
average number of errors of 3.35 in each
code
if you have three error you get 5.144
and yeah now you can kind of extract
some finite length information from this
if you think of this as a sequence of
thresholds that depended on n
you know that this limit has to be equal
to this
this these lambda stars and so if
there's n is large enough you can kind
of guess
it's not approval a threshold from this
you still have
i mean this still assumes they have some
kind of genie or something
so so this leads us to an open problem
so you you can make this analysis
rigorous
if there's a genie preventing
miscorrection you can use a much more
random graph and make it rigorous
using density evolution if you have
miscorrection
i do not know how to make this analysis
rigorous with miscorrection
i think it's possible but what you have
to do is you kind of have to have
a slight correlation between your errors
and still have it work
so because what happens is when you
miscorrect you always go to a code word
so the errors have some structure and
they just don't have very much structure
so
does that answer your question but in
practice do you see that right
so in practice if you want to get the
right threshold it's better
almost to assume you have miscorrection
and your graph is completely random
and so like this is the analysis we did
for gldpc and this kind of thing
that gives you a better estimate of the
threshold
this may be a strange question how much
more do you have
just curious uh four four okay how much
when did we start
okay so it's just two minutes
i think it's fast we'll see all right so
in fact it's just plots and description
of puts
so i wanted a fair comparison so because
of numerology i can't get an exactly
fair comparison so i had to match the
rate exactly
and let the block link stiffer a little
bit so my product code is a 170 154
shortened bch code which corrects two
errors its minimum stopping distance is
nine
in the iterative decoder if i take the
half part of code i can get a three
error correcting
code and the block is a little longer
but it has exactly the same rate
you'll see its minimum distance is
larger because it's this anti-symmetry
and even its stopping distance is larger
because i went to larger code
okay when you do iterative decoding
again assuming the genie
now we can guess these thresholds and if
we use the guesses we see that we expect
the half part of code to perform better
than the product code
from a approximate analysis of density
evolution
and when we do it we actually see that
so we see the blue code
curves are for the uh product code and
the red curves are for the half product
code
and you can also write down the error
for the arrow four is actually going to
be lower
for the half product code as well but
we're not we'll never see it it's 10
minus 14. all right we won't see it with
my simulations how's that we need
hardware okay so that it's not there is
some
we there is some gain here
all right and so the other thing is now
what happens when we go
so that was going from a to error
correcting code to a three-year
correction code
so the total length was what again was
like square oh
yeah so 28 900 here and 32 000.
so these are not these are not obscene
links i don't think
all right all right so now we have a
case where we don't get better
but we know why we don't get better so
the product code
is now a three error correcting code and
it has rate 186 here's its parameters
and half product code is based on a 511
uh
you see that right yeah for our correct
npch code
it's it's here's the links and what we
see now is that stopping distance is
slightly lower but the bigger problem
is if you use density evolution when you
go from a three error correcting to a
four
correcting code you actually don't get
as much as you should
it's a lot like raising the degrees of
your ldpc code you say i'm going to go
from degree three degree four
oh that should be better but under
density evolution it's not
and so you have exactly that loss
now as we've heard many times we expect
if we spatially coupled these which you
can do
they're called braided block codes that
would go away we would
but so this one we actually see the
product code performs better than the
half product
all right so my conclusions so half
product codes the length and dimension
are basically reduced by half with the
same components
uh the normalized minimum distance is
basically improved by three halves
and for the same block length you can
increase t by square root two
when you go from two to three this
almost always improves performance from
three to four it's a little more of a
wash
or slight loss now
in terms of open problems and this is in
this ita paper we have up
there's a natural generalization to this
to m-dimensional you pick an
m-dimensional product code with the same
code
you acquire the whole thing as an
anti-symmetric tensor
that means when you look at it you
interchange any two indices
it negates the value almost everything
goes through
you can show that the minimum distance
again is going to jump up
but we couldn't figure out by exactly
how much it didn't have such a nice
simple characterization
um and so uh but we we think it it could
be large
it let's say this it could be as large
as exponential and m
so i'll stop
two questions about the last uh remark
you might it doesn't
show up anymore as a generalized
hemingway three or four
so my guess might be that it's the
product of d
d2 d3 d4 i couldn't prove that i don't
even think it's right
that was my first guess it's the product
of the higher weight
no no no that's just random guess so we
played with it
and we did not get anything um but
so i guess you can show you know at
least you don't lose when you go to the
third dimension you've already gotten a
little larger
but um but it's i don't know
it's either more complicated or there's
a trick we didn't see
and one more question uh you showed all
the examples for heming
for uh pch codes yes bch
can't you choose the component codes in
such a way to
to try to optimize the stopping distance
or try to
come up with the better choice for the
component code that would boost your
stopping distance so
so the only better choice in these
regimes than than hamming codes would be
like
obvious h codes would be preparator or
corrupt codes
and so yeah and we compute the stopping
distance or did you compute it by search
or do you have a formula no no i can
find i can show you the patterns
there the so the stopping patterns are
these little square patterns maybe with
a diagonal missing they're kind of
so for we have a code with a certain nk
and a certain d min and there's no code
with that nk and a larger d min
here do you know of our example
yeah so the the same that was the eight
four four hamming the same thing happens
with the seven four
three hemming uh sydney i think happens
with a single product as
single parity check um i have a guess of
maybe one more but i don't know of any
more for sure
so um yeah it's probably not true it's
really because they're small and
everything's just right
it's not going to be a general statement
for sure just following up on that
what about higher dimensions in three
dimensions and the hamming code if you
take it
no in the paper i mentioned i give a
construction for the three-dimensional
one
it does not have that property so it's
it's minimum distance like we could try
and guess the formula from it
but its minimum distance does go up more
than you'd expect
i don't know the formula it does not
match the best known code
thank you